joining me now is harmony Dillon
California RNC committee woman also with
me is Kurt schlichter senior Congress
for Town Hall media all right Army let's
start with you what in the world is
wrong with California because I don't
know that we have enough time in the day
to go through everything but give us
your Top Line grievances
well thanks for having me you know when
you look at the whole state of
California it's actually a red State
it's this it's this blue loony strip on
the coast where Kurt and I happen to
live that is doing all these crazy
things and indeed we are driving so many
people out of California that we lost a
congressional seat in the recent
redistricting so I live in San Francisco
and you know it was a beautiful city
very pleasant to live and work in and
walk around but in the last few years
it's become unlivable the poop on the
streets the needles the drugs Scott
weiner is my representative in the in
the state senate and so uh 1.7 million
could buy you maybe two median homes in
in California instead it's buying
non-functioning toilets so the the
lunatics are running the Asylum here and
unless we Republicans get strong and
begin to take back all these places in
our country
it is going to California's misery is
going to become the country's Misery we
have Kamala Harris number two in line to
the presidency and Gavin Newsom lurking
in the wing so we have to stop this
madness
yeah I am into that uh all right Kurt uh
a California county has passed an
ordinance that will ban landlords from
conducting criminal background checks on
prospective tenants the Alameda County
Board of Supervisors voted four to
nothing on Tuesday the ordinance will
prevent private and public landlords
from requiring applicants to disclose
arrests or convictions
I mean are they just trying to force
more people to Utah Arizona and other
parts of the country what are they doing
well I think they are Jason I mean look
I'm a trial lawyer so California was
designed to make you know enrich people
like me you know social parasites and
other people who contribute nothing
um so so I haven't left but most of my
conservative friends have and um you
know and it and it's heard me pointed
out we lost a representative this year I
just saw an interesting statistic today
if current trends continue California is
going to lose three or four maybe even
five more representatives in the 20 30
sentence census which I think is a great
thing look I came here in 1972. it was
the Golden State Ronald Reagan was
governor I was just a little kid but you
know California meant I could do what I
wanted I could live my dreams and I did
I came back from the Gulf War I became a
lawyer got a firm did stand up comedy I
got to write best-selling books I get to
write for Town Hall I got to be an army
officer and and work on California
disasters of which we had many
but that dream is dying for younger
people and it kills me Jason to see
young people growing up in a California
where their dreams can't come true
well and and that's the sad part about
it I mean no undoubtedly has great
weather but uh harmeet I want you to
listen to this one La business owner
detailing his experience with crime in
the area watch this
it's so bad that we have employees being
attacked to and from their cars every
day on the way to work we have three to
five storefronts smashed per month the
the typical weapon of choice is a six
inch knife uh cast iron six inch pipe or
a sawed-off fishing rod that's how bad
it is and that's what normal pedestrians
and Shop owners have to face every day
Harmony what's your experience with this
oh absolutely correct the district
attorney there is our former San
Francisco district attorney and we have
open Warfare in the streets particularly
they're picking on people who are
vulnerable of course people don't have
weapons in these cities it's virtually
impossible even after the recent changes
that the United States Supreme Court to
get a carry permit here in San Francisco
they haven't granted a single one and so
law-abiding taxpayers who are prosperous
are sitting ducks for criminals with no
recourse whatsoever and that is
absolutely accelerating the flight out
of out of California but this is
happening in other states as well you
know California gets the giggles and the
blame but actually this culture and this
ethos is being exported to the entire
United States and you know we're
powerless right now with the you know
Democrats running the show in D.C you
saw what happened yesterday with the
Omnibus Bill to do anything about it and
so that is why we're really one of the
reasons I'm you know running for RNC
chairman to make sure that the
Republican Party fights back on these
issues aggressively all over the country
all right so I I got just a few seconds
here but uh Kurt Governor news have just
revealed that this year alone California
seized enough fentanyl to potentially
kill the entire population of North
America twice your thoughts
uh you know well there are solutions to
that and I think uh I think our meets
listed them and by the way I strongly
support her candidacy for RNC chair I
think we need that change and we need
conservatives fighting for conservative
values Gavin Newsom is going to come out
of California and try and make all
California into uh you know the crime
and hobo infested hell holes that Los
Angeles and San Francisco have become
we've got a fight back we've got to stop
it we have to draw the line and then
we've got to take our Golden State back
because it's a beautiful state with
beautiful weather heck I'm wearing
shorts and it's December 23rd don't pan
down what we believe you let's just
we'll stick right there all right Harvey
and Kurt uh Merry Christmas thanks so
much for joining us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else